(ambient music)
(audience cheering)
- Welcome back, my
guest tonight is,
he is the President of the
Syrian National Coalition.
Please welcome to the
program Hadi al-Bahra.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)
Welcome to the program.
You are the President of the
Syrian National Coalition.
What is that?
And is that, because
we're awfully confused,
and, by the way,
sorry for destabilizing
the whole region,
but what is the Syrian
National Coalition?
What is it made up of?
- The Syrian National Coalition
is simply proud Syrians
who seeks their justice,
to regain their rights,
their freedom, and
to have their country
with democratic rulership.
- Your goal is not
just the defeat
of this new terrorist group.
This ISIL, this ISIS,
whatever they call themselves.
Your goal is also to
gain justice from Assad.
- True.
- [Jon] Yes.
- Assad is the sole cause
of terrorist
organizations in the area.
This has been since the 80s,
since the invasion of
Lebanon by Syrian Army.
Since the presence of the
American forces in Iraq.
The origin of ISIS organization,
it was the Islamic
state of Iraq,
and it was carrying
terrorist attack
against American forces
in Iraq at that time.
Again, he invested and he
brought this same organization
to terrorize the
Syrian people now,
in order to block
their free movement
for freedom and democracy.
- Assad did that, because
our understanding of ISIS
is that they were
fighting Assad.
That they were, along
with the Al-Nusra Front
and the Free Syrian Army,
were all fighting together,
or not necessarily together,
but to try and defeat Assad.
- Opposite.
- It's the opposite.
- Assad never fought ISIS.
ISIS never fought Assad
since the start of the year
and the start of the presence
of ISIS inside Syria.
Actually ISIS fought only
the Free Syrian Army.
And Assad has bombed,
carried air strikes
against the Free Syrian Army
while leaving totally
ISIS forces out.
Go Google it out.
See how many air raids against
ISIS carried by Assad regime
since the start of the year.
You'll find nothing.
All the strikes are
against civilians,
against people inside
Aleppo using TNT bombs,
and using extreme violence
against his own people.
- I'm a little sad that
we don't know that here,
and that we could Google it,
and then we would know it.
- Yes.
(laughter)
- That's a little sad.
Why would Assad,
who's essentially,
this is the Alawite kingdom,
and he's supported by Iran.
Why would he unleash a Sunni
fundamentalist
terrorist organization?
Wouldn't they be
his mortal enemy?
- No.
He wanted from the start
of the Syrian revolution,
he had a strategy and plan.
He wanted the free world to
see that it's only a choice
between an evil
terrorist organization
and an evil dictatorship.
And he assumed that
the world would choose
the lesser of the two evils,
and they would choose
Assad to cooperate with.
Luckily, the free world
refused to do this,
and they understood the game,
and they stood by
the Syrian people.
- Are you concerned?
You know, I think the
sympathies of the world
are with this coalition of
people who just want freedom,
they just want to be left alone,
they just want to
live their lives.
How do you combat Assad
is backed by Iran,
and in some ways
backed by Russia?
ISIS, ISIL is backed
by maybe Assad.
Maybe they're getting money
from some of the other
more fundamentalist
regimes in the area.
How is a group like this
going to defeat them
and create something stable?
- Mainly by our will,
and our patience.
This is the future of our kids,
our granddaughters and son.
We have been fighting
them since 40 years,
and the world has kept silent.
Nobody moved.
They moved only against ISIS.
Why they didn't move and
do anything for Assad?
- [Jon] Mm-hmm.
- But we, the people of
Syria will carry on our fight
and will fight until we
win back our freedom,
and we'll achieve our quest
into a democratic society.
- How would you...
(applause)
I wish you very well with that.
So now a coalition has formed
that they are going to
do strategic air strikes
that they believe
will weaken ISIS.
Will they weaken them
to the extent that,
is this some sort
of round robin?
Does the free Syrians have
to fight and defeat ISIS
and then take on Assad?
Because it seems that the
coalition is unwilling
to utilize their
power against Assad.
- Well, our American
friends here,
they have to know that we
have been fighting ISIS
since the first
quarter of this year.
We have been fighting
two fronts all the way.
We've been fighting ISIS and
the regime, Assad regime,
at the same time with very
little help of the world.
We cannot carry on the fight
on two fronts at the same time
without the assistance
of our friends in the US,
and other free world.
- If we give you weapons,
can we put labels on them
because we have a tendency
to get weapons over there,
and then the bad guys
come and take them
because we tend to leave.
- I guess we have passed this.
As you know, ISIS
has went into Iraq,
and they already
captured all the weapon
provided to the Iraqi armies.
But for us, we are fighting
for our own freedoms.
We have been handling
sophisticated weapon system,
anti-tanks weapons, and
they are very well kept
within the hands of
the Free Syrian Army.
- Can you work also with
the Iraqi government?
Will they work in
concert with you
to help defeat
these two menaces,
and to stabilize the region?
- It's not anymore
Syrian problem.
It's not anymore even
the regional problem.
It is an international problem.
We are talking about
an organization
with 30 different nationalities
within this organization.
- [Jon] Right.
- You have Americans, you have
British, you have French--
- Have you seen and
up-tick in support?
Have you seen and up-tick
in coalition support
going your way since
all this occurred?
You're here for the UN mission.
Are you getting the help
that you think you need,
and that your people deserve?
- I think the world has started
to move in the right direction.
It's not to our
expectation as of yet,
but I think slowly it will
build up toward that direction.
They need to notice that they
cannot eliminate terrorism
by only military operations.
It has to be much, much more
than military operation.
You have to have a
social, political program.
You need to provide a
vision of political life
for all the region
in the Middle East.
- I think that's the
fascinating part.
Can you stick around
for a little bit?
- Sure.
- We'll come back, and
then I want to talk about
what could work there because
it's something that I think
America thought
they tried in Iraq,
were not successful with.
Thought they were
trying in Afghanistan,
were not successful with.
What a world like
that would look like,
I think would be important
to find out, to delineate.
Alright, so we'll be right back.
Hadi al-Bahra,
we'll be right back.
(ambient music)
(audience applauding)
- We're speaking
with the President
of the Syrian National
Coalition, Hadi al-Bahra.
Thank you for joining us.
Obviously this is a very
difficult time in your country.
You are based in Turkey now.
You can't be based in Syria
because they would
come after you.
- Yes, our head office
is in Istanbul, Turkey,
but our people
exist inside Syria.
We have the local councils, we
have seven different steams,
we have police force
inside the liberated areas
under the control
of the opposition.
- What has been the reluctance
of a country like Turkey
to involve themselves
in the fight,
and to not close
down the borders,
and to keep them so porous
in terms of black market oil
going back and forth,
fighters going back and forth?
How difficult is it to get
them to close that down?
- You cannot look
at it this way.
Turkey always faces very
hard, tough choices to make
because either they go in
the strict security system,
where they will not allow the
easy flow of Syrian people
out of Syria, inside
Syria, and food and supply.
The other option is to let
the humanitarian convoys
and the free movement of
the Syrian people easier.
Always Turkey chose to stay
on the humanitarian side
of the problem, risking
its own even security.
But today, as we
heard in the news,
that Mr. Erdogan has announced
his support to the coalition,
and he said Turkey
cannot stay any longer
outside of this coalition.
- So you believe we have reached
a certain coalescence point
where the world will
take this seriously now,
and it will change
things on the ground?
- It has to be changed.
It's a risk you
cannot ignore anymore.
Should we wait until we
see these guys all over
in the United
States, or in Europe?
We are your front line.
We have been fighting as I said,
from the first quarter
of this year alone.
Isn't it enough, or about time
now for you to support us?
Now you are supporting
with the weapons,
with supplies, with
the humanitarian aid
which you should do more
aggressively with us
because we are the front line
in the war against terrorism.
- Is it difficult
as you observe this,
to watch our Congress not
come back from their break
to talk about it?
Is that seem like an abdication
of a responsibility
in your eyes?
- For us, I mean we look at
our own national interests,
and our way of life,
as the American people,
they don't feel
the danger of this
because it's far away
from their homeland.
But for us, we can
foresee its problem
to our national interest, to
the region, and to the world.
So we should I think, all of us,
we should be more
responsible in this.
- What does a stable
situation look like?
Because the entire region,
I mean you can distill
the conflict in Syria,
but the entire region
is sort of trapped
between these despots,
and terrorists.
You have autocracies, and you
have these Islamist groups
that are bringing
terror, and it seems like
there's a large majority
of people in the middle
that are caught
between this fight.
- No, for us as Syrian people,
we seek democracy
and freedom for all.
We seek protection of
all the Syrian people.
You know Syria is
unique in its position.
We have many ethnicity,
many religious in our land.
Syrian society is
open, moderate society.
Syria's the only
country in the world
where you have people who speak
in the tongue of
Jesus, until to now.
If we were extremist country,
you wouldn't find these guys.
- No, no, no.
That's my point, I think is
that it's a moderate people,
but they're trapped between
extremists and authoritarian.
- I think the whole
region will have to move
into more democratic
type of government
procedure and systems.
I think it will move.
It started already
in Tunisia, in Egypt,
and other countries.
Nobody can move against
the movement of history.
I think Syria will
be the cornerstone
of democracy in the region.
- And your group is working
to rebuild that civil society.
Have you created enough of
a free zone for yourselves,
that there's at least
some semblance of safety
for at least that group?
- As you know, until
now we don't have
a free zone inside Syria.
We control land, but we don't
have air defense for it,
so daily these areas been
bombarded by Assad regime
using TNT barrels,
all type of bombs.
- So if they did a no-fly zone,
would that be at
least the first step?
Create a no-fly zone over Syria?
- This should be the
first thing to consider
in order to provide this
swift transition of power
inside Syria and allow
people chance to live
a little normally in
the liberated area,
and to start, look,
and build their future.
- Is the drawback to that,
that Iran will not allow that,
or that Russia will
not allow that?
Who is standing in the way of
a no-fly zone over that area?
- Well I think only Russia
and Iran are the front
opposing this no-fly zone.
- Okay, so we have
to go to a war with,
alright, hold on.
Let me work this out.
I'm just working out this math.
- I don't think
they will go to war.
If you remember when
the chemical attack
which Assad carried out
against his own people,
and 1,400 people died.
- Yes.
- The US put a red line,
and threatened
about using force.
- Yes.
- When Assad felt that the US
is serious about using force,
he backed out, and he
signed the agreement
to disarm and let go
of his chemical weapon.
Russia at that time, said
they are not ready to fight
for any regime in the area.
So all what we need,
we need the resolve
by the US and by our friends,
and really to tell
Assad enough is enough.
If we treat the sole cause,
for sure we'll be 50% away
in our fight against terrorism.
- And you feel this will
not trigger or create
a deeper fault line
between the Sunni
and the Shiite community?
You don't feel like
that will trigger--
- It is not a sectarian war.
It is Assad tried to make
it as a sectarian war.
He had tried to ignite it.
Until now, he could not.
- Well I wish you all the best.
I know you have a book.
- I have one bracelet which
I've been asked to give you.
- So we're going steady now?
I think is what's happening.
(laughing)
We are.
This is what's remarkable.
I want to get to this.
- I have this great
book to remember
the first 100,000 people killed
in Syria by Assad regime.
This project was carried
out with the dream
started by a nice American
lady here, Mrs. Lina Sergie.
I would like to give
it to you with some--
- It's astonishing.
This is a book of 100,000
that have been killed
during this terrible war,
and you were telling me
that there are another
100,000 that they could put--
- Now it's over
than 200,000 people.
- Well here's the hope that
there will be no more books,
and that you will find the
peace that you're looking for.
I really appreciate
you being here.
(applause)
Hadi al-Bahra.
(cheers and applause)